What do you do with autumn salmon Uh,
that medicine is made by a magician's knot
, isn't it?  So, if the patient dies,
I'm going to fall into ignorance, and I'm going to
fall into ignorance.
[MUSIC] It
was a hit to make new
I told you, just by persuading you can't fix your mind
Pale
, you can change your opinion and your personality to suit your needs It's
easy if you fiddle around with your brain
Boots I'm giving up on peace already I'm a girl who will hurt you for the rest of my life So I'll
come help you Don't be afraid, the anesthesia will take effect immediately
Money  As a
company, I always thought that if God had made people healthy in mind and body, people
wouldn't have suffered from illness or
war.I won't forgive
people.  I made a loving existence so full of flaws Let's create an
incompetent, clumsy loss
I'll fix everything
Let's give life to a dying but weak body Let's make a perfect heart for a weak heart that hurts others  Let's
why does anyone
care because without missing
I will make up
[music]